be the best you you can possibly leave
my life of the testimony and itself into
speaking things into existence and you
know living the dream content is King
content well we win
hello belief nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from actor and
entrepreneur Nick Cannon and my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
five is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always as you're listening
if something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down the comments
below and put it in quotes so that other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well
enjoy
I'd always say I kind of give out the
same advice about one first being a self
motivator getting up there and because
there are so many naysayers there's so
many haters there's so many people are
gonna say you can't do this there's so
many people who love to poke holes and
everyone's ideas that you have to build
yourself up every day you have to be the
one to say no this idea is brilliant
this will happen this is going to you
know speaking it into existence be the
best you you can possibly be and offer
up what only you can offer up and you
know a lot of people make mistakes it
for arrogance or conceit no that's not
what we're talking about we're talking
about straight company just sitting up
straight walking in a room on in the
room demanding attention what it's all
about I definitely have to be delicate
in sensitive and professional at all
times when expressing your views and
there's a time and place to say certain
things and you know at times certain
partners may not agree with what I have
to say or ever run into there all the
time but you know what at the end of the
day I tell people this often I'm not a
role model I'm a real model a role is
something that you play if you want you
know the character that you may see here
but the thing about being real in every
brand what every brand wants to be it's
authentic and and that's who I am as an
individual so yeah you're not going to
agree with everything I have to say
you're not going to like everything I
say but at the end today you can say
he's real to who he is into his
community there are some great wise men
in our community still and I feel like
people don't take advantage of tapping
into those resources of people like
Harry Belafonte Sidney Poitier and
Quincy Jones all of those type of people
who are still here have done it or paved
the way and have accumulated so much
knowledge and information and they have
it and we just got to go in there and
tap in and get it's about the self
generation that'd be a self-generated
and that's not waiting for anybody you
got to go out then do it yourself one of
the reasons why cory gunz is one of the
hottest MCs in the streets is because he
did it themselves he didn't wait on a
record label we're getting right on
somebody to come in and say I'll take
you here you just did it he would get
out there and that's and that's the
mentality of the young people today the
Millennials they just get out there and
they put forward and that's kind of how
you separate yourself from the pack
whether it's with the mixtape whether
it's with a demo reel whether whatever
it is if you get out there and do it
yourself people are going to acknowledge
that you're they're going to acknowledge
an effort I love to inspire people and I
believe you know my life is a testimony
in itself into speaking things into
existence and you know living the dream
and just kind of you know just
recognizing what you want to be in life
and achieving it in that sense so I just
want to get out there kind of explain
that and just you know you optimism and
even in these times it's like you got to
be able to wake up with a smile and go
down feeling really good I know it can
get tricky at times I'm sure you guys
already discovering how complicated life
can be out there and it can really be
hard on those dreams or the things that
you really feel like you really want to
accomplish but it's really not in your
grasp right there so I'm asking you
please hold on to those dreams never
give them up don't let go you go hold on
to them are you going to hold on to us
it is difficult at times is making sure
it's perceived properly and you know
because yeah I have the ability and the
finances to be able to to produce and
direct and create what I want to create
but then now that I've done that with my
own finances it's making sure that it's
a part of the community and and that
sometimes could be an inner struggle but
again content is King content will
always win so it's all about what you
make and how you make it in a statement
that it makes recently we had the
opportunity myself and you know one of
my mentors Spike Lee created the film
chiraq anything we did it in an
unorthodox way you know and amaz
was the partner with spike on that and
we didn't go the traditional route and
it got some amazing critical acclaim and
a lot of attention sighs beep time hey J
there take five Tron stare day trying to
get my head straight city s I reckon
[Music]
Benghazi but you know a studio would
have never made that film and or even in
it was a gamble in how the world would
perceive it and you know Amazon took
that gamble with Spike but I feel like
the more that we do those type of things
and create opportunities and step out
and say yeah we're not gonna go to
traditional route where these four
Studios are allowed to greenlight
something we're going to do it on our
own or we're going to partner with you
know an outside partner a you know
assuming partner that maybe isn't
normally considered to be here a go-to
person in the music industry I mean on a
movie industry we've got a step out
there and literally make something out
of nothing created if you want it be
livid Waukee generate it nice I'm
claiming it right now yeah you got to do
you think that that's one of the keys to
success or it has been for you just
claiming it and stick it into existing
the Walkman being about even it you know
even that idea faking it till you make
it I mean that's what hip hop was built
on right think about it you got to
really step out on it and when others
are gonna say now you can't do it say no
I can be done it just hasn't been done
before and I'll be the first to do it
multi-talented host of America's Got
Talent is the thousand good heat soup
skill the topical display
don't you be the judge Nautilus number
one
the three-time MVP of this event
recruits every day that it's not the
size of the dog in the fight
you know
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Patrick Reed
asked me to if there's someone you're
likely to profile in the next top 10
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote I'd also love
to know what was your favorite message
from this video what did you learn from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow in your life
or in your business please leave it down
the comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
chatter - Mel carpenter Mel thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting the interview
on your youtube channel and a review on
your blog I really really really
appreciate the support and I hope you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
it's all about the mouthpiece baby got
to be able to talk the game talk like a
boss move like a boss talk the hustle
that's what it all is so it all comes
for me at least being able to speak
things into existence and being able to
talk your way in any room and talk your
way out of any situation that is hustle
up and you know I use my age as an
advantage but at the same time it can be
a disadvantage in many different
scenarios a lot of times people were
saying oh that's just a young kid going
there so that's somebody who has some
money and doesn't really know what to do
with it so sometimes I got to stepping
in and be a shark about it and let
people know that hey don't let the stuff
that you know or that you think you know
me the TV shows and all that silliness
for you I'm a businessman and I've
always been a businessman my businesses
are definitely my life my passion this
is what I was born to do this was placed
on the planet for
I definitely consider myself a
small-business owner and it starts with
me open up our sport as a strong
consumer electronics business started in
the world of head phones and tablets we
have a record label called incredible my
fashion brand is something that I'm
extremely excited about ties mean so
much they stand for power and I want to
just be a celebrity for the clothing
line now I want to learn the business I
enjoy every aspect of everything that I
do my momentum is contagious it's a
tidal wave when it comes and comes
crashing in and it takes over the entire
room can't stop us because we always
want to go